it looks like the jungle it has the same
sense of permanency the same squalor but
this isn't the Calais camp 30 miles to
the south it's a new growing migrant
settlement the demolition of the jungle
hasn't even begun but already this is
the consequence new camps are popping up
across northern France by day they seem
mellow we're welcomed until recently
this place was home for just a few dozen
now more than 300 are here all East
African from Eritrea Ethiopia and Sudan
they're keen to show us why they say
they escaped their homes political
oppression and brutality nasara Deen
tells us he's here alone and just 16 he
may well be but he's no papers to prove
it working out who's telling the truth
here and who's chancing it is one of so
many complications how does any european
government assess who should get asylum
and who shouldn't regardless the
conditions they're in here and in the
jungle a truly horrendous and the
effects on their health is clear in the
distance less than a mile away a service
station a truck stop and the motorway to
Calais in the UK beyond in the ditch
next to the truck stop we find plenty to
suggest that the migrants are here
regularly but to see what they do here
you need to be out at night we drove
back to the same service station at just
after half past 10 but because of what
unfolded over the next 20 minutes we
only have garage CCTV to show bits of
what happened we arrived on the
forecourt and moved away towards the
ditch area on foot we'd been welcomed
earlier by the migrants we felt no
threat another security camera picks up
a small group moving towards us
we spotted them and filmed briefly but
then two dozen turned up rocks were
thrown followed by a sustained attack
with knives and sticks until we reached
our car cut bruised and without one of
our cameras what we experienced here
last night was frightening these men are
evidently violent and they're dangerous
they wrestled us to the ground and they
hit us and it's not unusual it's
happening here on a nightly basis you
can see in the undergrowth right next to
the petrol station where they gather
waiting to get on trucks and it's not
just at this location but at petrol
stations and port approach roads right
across northern France weekly truck
drivers film the attacks
Dave King is a volunteer at the jungle
he's been in and out of the place for a
year now and he knows it better than
most if we take the view that they're
all a bunch of thugs then that's
absolutely wrong if you take the view
that's they're all a bunch of poor
innocent refugees here Ron no it's a
community of 10,000 people with some
wrong ends there and as there is in any
community of 10,000 people but to make
the diluted judgment on the entire
community based on the activities of one
small element
there's nonsense what is clear is that
the authorities here still have no real
grip on this vulnerable people are
suffering and the violent core is free
to roam mark stone Sky News in northern
France